major developments in the confirmation
battle over Brett Kavanaugh the white
house giving the FBI the go-ahead to
expand its investigation of the Supreme
Court nominee by interviewing anybody at
deems necessary this is a source tells
Fox News the bureau's probe could wrap
up as early as tomorrow president
Trump's standing by his nominee in light
of the latest FBI review this is now
their seventh investigation so it's not
like that you know just starting I want
them to do a very comprehensive
investigation
whatever that means according to the
senators and the Republicans and the
Republican majority I want them to do
that I want it to be comprehensive I
actually think it's a good thing for
Judge Kevin Orr now with that being said
I'd like it to go quickly and the reason
I'd like it to go quickly very simple
it's so simple because it's unfair to
him at this point
meanwhile after demanding this FBI probe
Democrats are predictably complaining
that it's not good enough well based on
some of the reports that we've seen this
weekend I'm very concerned about this
because the White House should not be
allowed to micromanage an FBI
investigation there's time you know the
thing is that every Senate vote matters
and there's there's time to get to the
bottom of it even if is seven days
that's bad enough but then to limit the
FBI as to the scope and who they're
going to question plus the Arizona
prosecutor we saw at the hearing last
week is dealing a blow to Democrats
Rachel Mitchell details in a memo why
she would not bring criminal charges
against Kavanaugh saying it's even
weaker than quote he said she said all
right Dana you missed this on vacation
this Cavanagh situation still happening
I kept tabs on it a little bit was able
to you know they have some wife that
thing called Wi-Fi over there in Spain
it is an absolutely remarkable week and
it's one thing Greg I don't think you'll
mind I reveal our text I said I can't
believe that I'm missed that week and he
said that's okay next week will be worse
so extremely compelling and some
interesting polling came out today from
Quinnipiac you're saying that 48% of
people polled voters polled said they do
not think it should be confirmed 42% did
but 56% think he is being this is part
of a political smear campaign and I
can't remember the other number and so
you're gonna see some more polling on
this there are basically four senators
now that this comes down to Murkowski
Blake Collins and then Manchin and
president Trump was in West Virginia
over the weekend there's incredible
pressure on senator Manchin because his
constituents and a number that is like
astronomical want Brett Kavanaugh to be
confirmed who take a risk for Brett
Kavanaugh this week for his nomination
not for him personally
is that now the hearings done now we've
got this FBI investigation as you said
the Democrats saying well that's not
good enough the Senator McConnell saying
today we will vote this week and in the
meantime you basically have dead air for
Brett Kavanaugh president Trump speaking
so passionately about his nominee today
from the Rose Garden helps fill that gap
a little bit but the news cycle moves so
fast President Trump has a rally tonight
he's got one again tomorrow
how long can he keep this going it's
really important I think for the nominee
and for President Trump to keep it in
the news on their terms
well he's high-energy enough so I think
he can fill the void this Mitchell
report Emily that came out and she was
you know nonpartisan sex crimes
prosecutor who the Republicans brought
in she released this letter that said
some really interesting things that she
would never ever bring charges in a case
like this and it is incredibly wreak
week for a number of reasons right and I
thought multiple things about that
report so first of all we're already
hearing backlash that she even submitted
a report which I found preposterous
because what is she gonna do text from
the plane like thanks guys that's a wrap
this was out sourced by the Senate
Judiciary Committee Republicans for her
to do a job so of course she's going to
issue a report then I'm also hearing a
lot of backlash from other prosecutors
saying well this wasn't a proper
investigation and that's not the
appropriate standard but
the bottom line is she did the absolute
best with what she was given and the
investigation in that closed world
she used the preponderance of an
evidence standard which is the lowest
and note this that to bring charges as a
prosecutor you the the standard for that
is that you have a reasonable belief
that the charges are supported by
probable cause and then also that
admissible evidence is supported by
beyond a reasonable doubt and that it's
in the interest of justice so she used
basically the lowest possible standard
giving it the lowest barter cross and
still found it insufficient so I found
the report absolutely telling and that
she should be given a lot more credence
than she is so what are the Democrats
out of bullets here we've had hearing
after hearing we he's produced more
documents and answered more questions
than any SCOTUS nominee and in history
and now we have a seventh FBI background
check is that gonna be enough well I'll
check your history I mean we've had much
longer confirmation battles in our
history but I mean to me what you're
seeing here one Ike I'm amazed at what
you just said about this prosecutor from
Arizona not being partisan she was
brought in because there were all male
Republicans and she was brought in by
the Republican side by definition is
that gonna take her partisan yes it does
and and and in fact as I recall Lindsey
Graham cut her up because he thought she
wasn't being effective and now she
decides she's gonna try to redeem
herself with her Republican buddies by
issuing this report which has no
standing because it wasn't based on any
kind of investigation or anything beyond
what he was able to gather at this
hearing from Democrats that they liked
this woman and she did a nice job that
was gentle if you burn the Democrats
purse so they're the Bears but here's
the thing I think the key point is the
look at the poll numbers that Dana
referred to you look at the Fox polling
Quinnipiac you look at Harris Harvard
it's all the same people don't believe
Cavanaugh they do believe her I think
that's what that's I mean unless you saw
a different poll I mean the question is
well clearly what I got is in the Fox
poll has 50% do not confirm 36 percent
believe Ford not care
but I think it's become tribal Dana I
think it's absolutely become traveling
in the latest polling what you see is an
uptick in terms of the number of
Republicans who are back encounter
previously by though is amazing to me
they didn't back Kavanagh to the extent
they back Neil Gorsuch this is not a
popular nominee but now in the midst of
the tribal warfare you see it tick up
and it takes up among Democrats as well
the key question for me though yeah in
terms of what we go forward is what is
the standard because what we've seen is
now I think it's for people who knew
Cavanaugh either at high school or
college or saying he wasn't forthcoming
and truthful about his drinking so if
you hold you this standard now you're
going to get Democrats who are going to
say this is a matter of character for
someone we're putting on the court for a
lifetime appointment and this guy's
lying about his drink that we lied about
any drinking 100 use the beer standard
the drinking standard Ted Kennedy comes
to mind Greg what do you think where to
start I hate the fact that we are using
polling to gauge someone's innocence
that is this is not a job interview this
is now the Coliseum in which we turned
to the crowd on whether or not we could
give the thumb up or the thumb down they
didn't just move the goal posts here
they just turned over the game board
because they knew they were in trouble
to the point about the if he's lying
about booze what else is he lying about
argument well it's clear that dr. Ford
lied about a number of things as well
you can call them inconsistencies that's
the nice polite way of saying lies
whether it was about about plane travel
she only has a fear of flying when it's
not on vacation
the polygraph she wasn't sure when it
was she said it was a devastating
experience but there were two questions
the claim that she never got a lawyer an
offer from the Republicans like Grassley
to take to have the meeting over there
giving notes to reporters changing
bystander to not bystander there's a lot
of in I'll be diplomatic and say
inconsistencies to her otherwise
credible testimony that's how you talk
apparently so if his lies about booze
which I do believe he fibbed about his
drinking because he's talking about his
drinking in front of his wife and kids
and I'm sorry I do the same thing when I
when my wife asks me how much I drank
over the weekend while she's away I say
not much
honey and she goes yeah right so the
fact is those lies have nothing to do
with the actual accusation but we're
talking since we're talking about
alcohol abuse let's talk about the media
and the Democrats who are obviously
alcoholics because they completely
blacked out the last five days
they do not remember that the third
accuser has a history of lying and
sexual misconduct claims lying about
unemployment lying about her education
but they don't seem to remember the
avenatti bombshell from last week which
is now a bombshell that she lied about
her background but that's somehow they
forget they blacked out about that they
blacked out about the Rachael Mitchell's
a memo worthy we're covering it all the
early reason we're covering it because
no one else is because they blacked out
these are huge things that the media
cannot remember because they don't want
to remember it it's it's disgusting you
know what though I mean you listen to
the president today the president's now
engaging in just the kind of Angry
bullying babe Oh Cory look way down
Richard Blumenthal is a liar it's all
these Democrats they aren't angels over
there I I know I've seen them in
compromise that great though it's next
wait they said great this is let me tell
you we are talking about a Supreme Court
nominee and a man and a family totally
denigrating the whole process it's now
been corroborated we're destroying a
person's life an uncorroborated
accusation that's right your your toy
your focusing is if this is just that
that's all about know you really did
destroy somebody over a seat I didn't
have the seating I would say I don't
tell you I've got bullets in me from
trying to defend someone when I thought
they were unfairly beyond Milan but I'm
going to tell you this when you look at
Cavanaugh you have to you just said you
think he's fibbing about the drinking
yes you've got to speak to a man's or
woman's care doesn't stay with them in
the street to the character of a guy
like trying to play down the
exaggerations over over beard a to the
point on that though Greg where's the
yearbook you guys stuff in there about
remember on the yearbook remember about
the devil astronomy when he turned baffi
yes no you were here
back to it you were selling books while
we busy that's me everyone through that
entire thing
drinking oh yeah it's not a sexual
position bhopping is not sexual being
and it's flatulent you know what we're
gonna ask me how I know I see your
yearbook
my whole one's here but please you don't
have to go that far